عوده الهواتف الغبيه
اتذكرون هذا الهاتف الصغير كم كنا سعداء
به وبعشرات من اخوته من الطرازات المختلفه
كان يؤدي الغرض الاساسي منه وهو التواصل
بين البشر عمره طويل ويتحمل كل انواع
الصدمات لم يؤذي احدا ولم يتعدى على
خصوصيه احد الى جاء من يزيحه عن عرشه
ويحوله الى شيء غبي في عيون الناس لا قيمه
له ولا فائده انه عصر الاجهزه الذكيه بين
حين واخر تطلق عشرات الموديلات الجديده من
الهواتف وملحقاتها
وتسبقها دائما الاف من البرمجيات
والتطبيقات الاكثر ذكاء تلك التطبيقات
قلبت حياتنا راسا على عقب وبقدر ما قدمت
من فوائد للبشريه تسببت بكثير من الازمات
والمشكلات امراض هنا وادمان هناك واختراق
وتجسس عائليه وغيرها الكثير كان عنوانها
الابرز الهواتف الذكيه
المشكلات تلك بدات تخرج عن السيطره ما ادى
على ما يبدو الى هجره عكسيه وحنين للماضي
لدى البعض لسان حالهم يقول هاتف غبي وحياه
طبيعيه افضل من هاتف ذكي وعالم ابعد ما
يكون عن الواقع
الاجيال الجديده نشات في عالم الهواتف
الذكيه لكن الامور الان بدات تختلف ما جعل
الهواتف الغبيه تشهد انتشارا جديدا بين
المستخدمين
شركه نوكيا رائده عصر الهواتف التقليديه
قالت انها استعادت جزءا من سوق الهواتف
المحموله عالميا العام الماضي مع تزايد
نسبه التخلي عن الاجهزه الذكيه والاقبال
اكثر على الاجهزه البسيطه
حقا انه من القلب لقد كان لدينا الكثير من
المستهلكين يطلبون اعاده بعض ايقونات
نوكيا القديمه وهاتف 3-10 بالتاكيد واحد
منهم كنا متحمسين لذلك وبالفعل عملنا على
اعاده هذه الهواتف الايقونيه الكلاسيكيه
الى المستهلكين
بين عامي 2018 و2021
قفزت عمليات البحث في جوجل عن الهواتف
الغبيه بنسبه 89% في المقابل وفي الصين
مثلا مبيعات الهواتف الذكيه في 2022 كانت
الادنى على الاطلاق منذ عام 2013
الكثير منا كان لديه هاتف غبي كاول هاتف
محمول قمنا بشرائه لذا من الطبيعي ان نشعر
بشيء من الحنين الى الماضي تجاه تلك
الاجهزه الكلاسيكيه
العوده الى الهواتف الغبيه ربما تمثل لدى
البعض عوده الى الحياه الطبيعيه حياه لا
يتواصلون فيها من وراء شاشات اللمس فحسب
حياه يمتلكون فيها الهاتف ولا يمتلكهم فهل
فكرتم يوما بالاستغناء عنها واتفكم الذكيه